all right and we are live the last word
with Luca Dino and a Baptist Friday
morning fresh by the campfire what is
going on sir how you doing I'm doing
good man had an awesome stream last
night finally check the box and we'll
talk about that here in a little bit a
little overdue for those who like to
accomplish these things but finally got
it yeah I'll talk about in a minute but
yeah streams have been good gamings been
kind of fun the world is crazy so just
kind of enjoying what we can right now
yeah so overall not too shabby I'll get
into my stuff here in a little bit but
what about you what you been up to man
it's crazy but you know gaming and doing
everything else I can to keep some
sanity but all for me it's been event
for ever picked up Streets of Rage for
my og gaming self forgot all the fields
back all the things I used to play back
in the day it's a tremendous job art
style is amazing so much fun oh man I
can't say enough about this game if
you're a Sega kid he grew up in the in
the area of the Genesis that was a cult
classic the old school beat them up so I
come from that you know Double Dragon or
like so yeah it is fantastic the art
style is straight up out of a comic book
so I've been doing that and on Gears
tactics I've been doing all games
tactics messing around doing my little
ex Comi type flow and of course some
Destiny's actually grinded off she
started my grind started to seriously
attack Guardian games because I really
need heir apparent I really want to saw
a shot of dad oh he had a good video out
and I'm like look at the DPS and
everything and I'm like alright it's not
as you know but it you guys assuming you
yeah I got it
you beast savage so I'm hearing good
things though like I mean once you get
revved up yeah I mean if you watch
anybody's like what you could do with
that thing don't like the arc shield is
kind of like thee you talk to me about
that kind of the equalizer to be like
hey it pumps out a lot of damage but if
somebody hits you with arc it's like an
enemy art shield basically if you pop it
into me arc shield with art you know
they give that pop they get kind of
staggered
yeah you're gonna take that same hit
you're gonna lose health you're probably
gonna lose most of your shield honestly
and take a chunk so yeah it's like the
first time it works the way an enemy
shield does mm-hmm but if you're in
place with a bunch of solar and void go
go to town because it actually like it
will recharge if you don't take too much
damage it's powerful and then the amount
of damage you can put out with that
thing's got 200 in the clip 500 magazine
without mods or 500 capacity without
mods
there's no 80s okay there is like a
little red dot so it's just a reticle
okay so we just kind of like kind of
zooms in it's like alright you ready to
fire it's just like you bring it closer
to you yeah that's about it
but overall I will be curious where that
thing becomes viable honestly because
like when I was what I was playing last
night I did pit of heresy solo solo
flawless let's get it yes that's all a
flawless pit of heresy last night
finally took about five attempts and
some other practicing and stuff but
actual like hey let me start this one
and not have a stupid death so Wednesday
night was probably my closest because
the hardest part in the entire thing is
the totems encounter always is gonna be
everything else is patient stupid deaths
and trust me I've had some stupid deaths
but it's the totems encounter with all
the crap going on in there there's
enemies coming from every direction
there's the acolytes there's the
grenades every orb that you dunk you've
got the Boomers the thralls everything
happening and I used 21% delirium
what are you we don't know now give me
the loadout the whole whole load up yes
let me guess the primary let me know
kinetic nope wrong no you wait a minute
yeah you to use your dad bod go figure
no what has come over you are you sick
oh you don't feel too well what's going
on so I needed this night you rock this
so it was revoke her for about multi
most of it just for range and distance
and stuff final section was Izzy's
energy energy was
little calamity for a good amount side a
bow in there for range submachine gun at
a couple points as well ya know go
figure
go figure doesn't actually have a real
good spot in that whole thing cuz if I
got a sniper I got extra range covered
and if you're going safe you're really
staying far away right and then if
anything gets on up on you and the caves
or up close together it's submachine gun
for like the ogre maze and then the
final section just mow stuff and the bow
is weird the bow is probably like so I
think I saw dad oh do it
eons ago too and it was the one reason I
thought about doing it but the main
reason I use specifically subtle
calamity is because that with a minor
spec I can one-hit Acolytes
during the totem encounter so if I go to
pull on one and I got one with moving
target and archers tempo so it's pretty
accurate fires quick if I could get
rampage you know and I'd be better but
not yet but I can one hit an acolyte and
I even had some that I could be like
because I had like explosive head or so
it'd be like fire and then delay and
it's like if I hit one in the face I do
not want them throwing their damn
grenades because the grenades suck in
there so anytime you're sitting on that
little totem air it's just like grenades
grenades
constantly constantly yeah so I finally
did bit of ever see you haven't done
that either I did it a while ago I never
did all this other stuff but I don't
know why oh I know why
shout out to scream what a problem
scream low-key ruin pit of heresy for me
because they like cheat wizard or
whatever yeah what he did I didn't even
do the actual thing I actually just got
xenophanes a head of time specifically
cuisine oh and I remember that there was
somewhere right we could skip to so
we're not guys you know I'm like oh yeah
I don't have to do it now it was and I
never got around in it but sinister he
hit me up he's like no let's get some
pinnacle is happy with ethical and he's
like not when I run pit I'm not you know
what I've never run it legit like mercy
I would do it
it's fun it's element yeah so did you
play shredder throne as well
yes so my discussion was asked last week
or the week before I think probably what
do you think between the two now that
you've kind of experience both dungeons
I know one's a lot fresher but still
yeah both the good arm I think I will
edge pit I think don't post encounter
when you have to reflect with the sword
and then you do anything I like that
little dynamic and then like the whole
it's like an arena right at that whole
last part then they're also part of
hiding from that ogre and sliding under
the tents you know saying now I was the
only thing I don't like maybe it's just
me is my brightness or something it is
so dark on my monitor like after just
brightness is I really struggle seeing
where things are when I'm jumping when
you'd like jumping around yeah I don't
know for some reason like I know what a
lot of it is scarlet coloured but
there's some areas for me that are
extremely dark and I'm just like yeah I
don't know what a lonely like little nip
you and my brother sound exactly the
same
he hates he hates anything shattered
thrown - he hates the taken like
corrupted space you so you know it's I
guess what it is is the aesthetic in
shadow shattered dream is so
consistently one kind of thing yeah that
I can understand people who arm you know
definitely get annoyed wait but shadow
donut don't get me wrong shout it throne
it's really good like I'm not gonna
disrespect its rid it's close but I just
I just like the the idea of that boss
and he's a unique thing and it just a
lot of things go there's not a lot of
like cuz we had seen the smashy nights
and stuff and they'd kind of yeah we'd
seen them a little bit and they mosey
around kind of slow pop their head off
so I'm gonna send in challenges and
other things and then it's another
wizard as opposed to a big boy fire
thing so y5e yeah is olmac I like the is
Oh Mac I like the idea of the descent
when you starting like you're descending
you going down you see you almost see
like a subterranean little city that's
what it feels like and you just go in
there well like the necropolis if you
sit at the top you can see the boss
stage from the top true and then I was
and that's what I've honestly wondered
for whatever their third
gonna be which hopefully is in the fall
well I mean you had shatter thrown you
can look and see the boss fight at the
top and then now you look down and can
see it in the pit and I'm going mm-hm
are we gonna be like going far away I'm
kind of curious cuz like the visual
piece of both of those has been kind of
a staple so I'm honestly wondering for
the third one if it's like if they keep
that going or at this point you won't be
able to see start to finish because it's
kind of cool that you can some slander
no neo meant to I do not need glasses
you need to stop oh well I have less of
it I don't need it for that I don't know
people tell me the same thing they
struggle seeing stuff in the jumps this
I don't know man you said stone said the
same thing oh no oh he just hates the
whole corrupted taking an area in
general so that's just normal via pity
yeah but yeah so I mean when you went
through so let's take it and counter by
encounter since you actually got the
full experience
necropolis so you've got the symbols and
then this is kind of your first
introduction into you'd probably known
about it by now but as you go for the
first time it's your first introduction
into like using the sword and the
different encounters of like I and I was
actually going through at one point
probably one of my random best and I was
just playing through and Prescott I
think it was Prescott that reminded me
or bender and I think bender oh I think
Prescott was the one that was with me
and we are trying to figure out how to
kill the frickin Shrieker and we didn't
know and it was like earlier because we
did it like first day it opened up or
something like that and we're like
trying to figure out the damn Shrieker
and I think we slowly tried to kill that
thing with our super or whatever because
I've never honestly like we hadn't used
swords very much hadn't been a thing and
they're like oh let me go ahead and
reflect yes never would have thought
that bad
that's a cool mechanic yeah that's the
easiest like for the three rooms though
cuz like the Shrieker has ogres the
wizard has two wizards and then the
Knight has just they're all I'm like the
easiest thing to kill with just the
reflection has the ugly ogres wizards
kind of in the middle and the Knights
like the easy-peasy ones so mm-hmm but I
don't know it's like just like that was
kind of an addition cuz you know
everything from shattered throne evolved
when it went over to pit of heresy so
shadow throne was like
okay so you got the jumping fish over
here you got the this bird sitting on
the thing over here but all you did is
just run to each area and kill the ads
like there was a boss in there but there
was no true mechanic and then you take
it to this one same thing you've got
different symbols to know which rooms
you need to go between and then but
you've got like the sword you've got to
kill you've got to run out to the bridge
get that go back in figure out which way
you gotta kill him so like each it was
an evolution of anything and stuff like
yeah so gave them the foundation and I'm
saying for them to take span wanna
completely agree what you save it's a
cool evolution and I'm dying to see what
they do for the next one man I'm getting
into the dungeons man I'm definitely
feeling them okay yeah so I honestly
haven't done the totem with people and
so long is the totem even like hard with
two people as much because I think
sinister told me just stand in the
corner put my well layer and then he got
busy you just you just stay up here you
shoot ads I'll go get all the balls and
dunk him and take care of it I was ad
clearing well of Radiance I have my
Phoenix Protocol going and we were just
generating so that part was pretty easy
I mean he did all the work I would just
sit there like okay you know say he
dunked the ball but it was fun it was
funny it gets intense it doesn't get
intense man oh no yeah it's chaos in
there so mm-hmm
Harry said he got a third Ted ten Chloe
to me yeah they gave me a I'm a bond and
I'm like home I mean it was masterwork I
will actually say that of all if you get
like one random piece the fact that like
there's no stats on that one would like
the stats from there so I actually got
what did I get last thing I think I got
67 on my masterworks helm or arms which
means it was actually a 55 stat rule so
it wasn't complete junk completely yeah
but I will say like all the master work
on the class item is actually like they
have no stats so if you have the plus 12
you're good to go now it's an old
seasonal mod but at least he got there
swell just about to say yeah because I
hurt now because I can't use the war
mind mind and I'm into my war my mods
now like I'm all about I got a cool
little flow the arm
ARC one that generates off of everything
mail a super whatever it's called tyrant
surge I did never smile that's my thing
then I coupled that and then I got the
one on the arms that's like um you use
it as an over shield you actually run
into the warm on cell and it gives you
like an over shield that's for like 15
seconds that's my build right there when
I'm doing hard content I'm looking for
that stuff and I got this sick um
Seraph shotgun with vorpal oh oh shot
the vorpal weapon man can we talk about
warble weapon let's go I really have an
appreciation for this thing yeah oh man
like vorpal is out of control like it is
really strong so I've been using that
and my um I'm like I think I have a
breach lightweight still and my um what
you call it Seraph shotgun dad dad has 4
point I'm just tearing things up it's
it's savage its savage what I'm doing it
easy yellow boys they not ready I was
like I feel like I have a vorpal and
everything from that was possible last
season I have so many rolls from last
season I haven't even like look through
but I swear I had I think we got a
vorpal option on it what like half the
weapons probably except probably that
auto rifle I slept on horrible big time
big yes Ares better bottom she's
chocolate oh yeah dude of which you know
which even it is it is really good
really strong so any crucible - yep oh
you like you kind of don't have fear of
supers the world is out doing its thing
yeah you guys don't know Cognito lives
somewhat near to the world of sirens
that's worth I think they test sirens
it's actually a siren testing Factory
no I'm just kidding not really he's
definitely X still like a firehouse or
something like that which is always just
good timing yeah they're making their
runs the siren testing factor out here
they go again yo he's doing a podcast go
go go put him on savage savage well yeah
one time very but yeah man vorpal I'm
loving that but I I can't I have to
admit man I was rough on them with
season of the dawn Mars what was
charged with like I don't relate too
much but these warm line sales I
literally can't go without running that
bill I was like and they're going away
in about five weeks yeah I know well
that's the pink suit and this is where
I'm kind of going go into some of this
stuff where I'm just going to naturally
get there but there's good seasonal mods
like the idea that like hey maybe we'll
bring some of these back and I'm like
well there's one of those if it's like
six energy so it's kind of a commit but
if you're holding a sword you take less
damage from enemies around you now I
toyed around with Pitt of heresies final
guy with and without that mod drastic
difference because I went against I
there was one time I was I think it was
last night or Wednesday night when I was
working because I was like all right I
dyed skirt we're gonna mess around with
the sword and I had like one issue but I
did a damage phase by myself with my
sword with at least more than half
damage in one damaged phase just with a
sword sit in a bubble sword and I have a
whirlwind relentless sword so an overlap
overload rounds on two on a sword well
okay I know I know that not that I'm
talking about like pit of heresy I just
put boss back on one but the overload is
amazing for captain's yes that too yes
but I was just sitting there and it
starts at like 17,000 damage and then it
goes up to like 23 something by the time
you're done so like the increase in
damage just bike and I'm just sitting
there swinging away on big dudes foot go
into town and I like literally I to
fazed him if I could I could to faze him
in my head again if I had good runs he
would be dead in two and it's just like
and that mod it takes six but it's like
six energy for your class item or
something like that me and I'm like okay
I'm going pull full-on sword but it was
like that goes away at the end of five
weeks so that's why I was like oh no
you're right you're right so like
because ya know it's just the fact that
I mean that and then some of them what
the all these mods you're talking about
the charge with light is kinda staying
around it seems like but these wore mine
cells are straight up they're gonna go
by the wall Mizar fish
I mean I'm trying to think of how the
mods work for no I guess those are gonna
stay if you keep the weapons huh
if so the war mine cells are just only
always gonna be available I guess so
yeah they're normal but like some of the
season but like the seasonal perk
whichever the arc one is where I feel
like any art damage you just like drop
one that ones cuz that was always the
biggest thing for me was the idea that
you couldn't always control when you'd
have one yes and and now I know I think
my brother was saying he's been toying
around with to where you can actually
pick him up take him with you take him
to the next room sin has that one yes
and he said that's huge because it's
usually the proximity is like hey the
last three or four guys in the room the
last one drops it you're like well I
have nothing to kill now what the hell's
the point mm-hmm so you can pick them up
and take them with you but yeah it's
like also just like hey I need to make
one arc damage hmm so I mean it's there
are there are certain ones that are fun
but it's also annoying that hey here
goes these seasonal mods and none of
them come back so like swords are fun
next this season because you got like
sword scavenger sword ammo like all the
time yeah I pick up one thing a sword am
like half full - I'm good to go yeah
never run out a sword ammo which is
really nice but ya know it's just the
weird like some of those mods like can
we get like a community vote for the
couple that want to stay around here so
I don't know man I know some of them are
mobile yeah some of them are a little
broken like the batteries always seem a
little bit broken and stuff but there's
some like hey swords are better cool
leave them in there or something I don't
know this is the most I've used swords
ever yeah like it's all straight up and
stay I got the what's the one the the
black armory one yeah well sure strikers
hand yeah use it that bad boy I mean
it's so much fun man I agree it's like I
had that problem with season of dawn too
because I had a bill that was wrapped
around my melee and my solar class and
then a twin I'm like oh you know it it's
cool because they introduced new things
now then you get sad when they take
way because you like they I mean I'm
saying now we got to see a whole new
bill but I will say this I want to UM
can we get some heavy BOTS or special
you know like could somebody's heavy
weapons that are underutilized get some
love you know it would be can we not
start with linear fusions please don't
start there yeah that should we do that
yes you do right snipers what it means
yeah it's like let me stagger a stagger
anything with like an a crit from a
sniper or yes just yeah like snipers
shotguns overload done right there like
and then you could sit there and
actually kill them to us be like hey let
me go pew pew okay now I can put some
damage into you let me just go at
shotgun T would just melt a guy that I
want to for a change is supposed to
feeling like this season's like barrier
and stuff like that I haven't done as
much they're there but it's like for
those who don't have area on us they're
kind of screwed right now yeah because
everything is sidearm submachine gun on
Latian I mean autos are okay but if you
want a little bit of range
you can't go exotic so they go exotic
yeah so there's so many and that I want
the mobs on Sonic's I'm dude that's go
and they have any that was good I
haven't even mentioned it they haven't
even addressed it yes they haven't
talked about it at all and we just have
this giant collection of mods out there
that's like there's about 60 weapons you
don't get to use them Onix fine I agree
I would love to use like especially
those old exotics you Devils ruin this
season Oh that'll be nice why not like
people busting out the Rat King
not imagine that like that'd be fun oh
man
Rat King would have been hilarious Rat
King would have been fun
Oh shouted Dan oh he said whenever I had
a little fusion I tear up you know you
were sleeping I used to sleep of baby -
yes leave a simulant man that's it was
perfect time to do it
the matically with this season - they
missed the boat man they missed an open
shot alone oh he's got a good arm wake
the sleeper campaign has because we got
we got to bring it back guess all that
yeah we gotta get that Cohen I'm Miss
Lee put it in its glory
man speaking of glory what's up uh
hardlight yes we've got a like onyx
squatted Pat's just BAM speedy patch oh
yeah let's go hard lights damage
fall-off now floors at point seven auto
rifles use a standard 0.5 so 30% less
damage at max range not gonna get those
crazy shots split ricocheted damage
which is they they split it PvE and PvP
PvE damage remains at 2.0 PvP damages at
1.35 removed a recoil adjustment that
made the weapon more stable than
intended I haven't seen like the review
videos of it posts I don't know how bad
it is how do you yeah it's still good
listen first of all this is a good day
this is a good day because you guys
fought this and I love the day broke
protocol they didn't even wait normally
Bungie would wait and we would have to
suffer for a whole season of nonsense
but good old buds UK thanks to all the
stitches out there who Pro called our
heart like saluting y'all man y'all
service your good reporting did this
justice to get this gun back in lot not
all jokes aside it needed it but it's
not that hard of a nerve it's still good
the only thing is which I said it needed
damage fall off you know I'm saying
shout the areas yes sir O's is tops in
the range you are correct I've been
using Searles earliest yeah if you're
lucky to have summoner summoner would do
the job but hardlight just needed to
damage fall-off and stop having people
shoot recklessly down corners and get
double you know whatever the damage was
double damage so you know it's still
gonna be useful and I will say this
shout to ask to cross because you got a
good video out and I agree if you got
the catalyst all this stability stuff
not issue like you're fine I think still
has a hundred aims its still peace and
let's be honest the majority of the
community has hardline but shout out to
disco era it was a good run we've
closing all the clubs now we're getting
back to normalcy no more disco music
let's go
so trials report Monday afternoon this
week what do you want what are you gonna
put on top of that board mmm I think
everybody's gonna flock
I think Soros is coming back I think so
well revoke is gonna beat it that's not
like revoking that whoa I'm saying
primarylike revoke er Mindbenders Summit
Lake so rule your Mindbenders those are
like those are special staples what are
your primaries it's gonna be it's gonna
be survive default just based on access
accessibility the key will be what's the
difference between Soros to fix your
face I already know where you go with
this Oh what's the difference be a you
don't don't be slick I know what his
questioning was going actually don't
know actually I thought you as good as
say well if har light gets interrupted
all everyone's gonna do is just go to
cirrhosis and blah you know that I would
expect a lot of it but certain even last
week seminar was higher than serous so
yeah oh wow oh really
yep yeah last week was hard light revoke
her cuz its burnouts he had hard light
revoke her almost even summoner was not
very far by and like 2.6 million 2.5
million summer was 2.3 million then mine
vendors Wow then so then the Saros
beloved bestie and astral spared us
truck so yeah the thing is Widom what
you call it with shout out yes Dini I
agree gotta have more skill with sorrows
um you get that get that spinning up
going but um I think that serves because
of a accessibility it will always be
there most Guardians have access but as
people are playing trials more
surprisingly during this climate people
are going to have summoner you know say
and so I'm gonna it's I'ma be honest I
have you do you have some or some but
yeah I know I need to I don't know what
shout the area via chat people who have
someone talk to me right now it's
something about this gun that even
though it says 600 even though it says
it feels like the rate of fire is faster
with summer it's something about it just
shoots super fast like if you get lined
up by it you're out of there so that to
me is the new wave I almost feel like
there's a hidden
yeah I got one said moment on mine too
yeah shut up Tara I got into a laser
beam it's a laser man so when more
people get a hold of it
you gonna that's what people go to
started complaining but that's what
people are gonna fear there's no doubt
about how's the range on it oh it's it's
pretty it's pretty solid
it's nice it's but it's more show the
rate of fire in combination with the
snap the handling the snappiness to it
don't quick it gets to it almost feels
like it has that shot almost
intrinsically it's so fast like it feels
quick just really high handling on it
yes handling it's super high like in the
80s compared to others a big six
hundreds in its class love the gun man
it's really shout that are I yes Tara
yes Gilly I don't yeah I even all my
stupid Ford runs no gallier it's always
easy to get it now it's easy wait into
um is it the nicest guy Oh burgoo Zia
its producer waiter burger Xia comes up
on the daily rotation I was in there for
forges for metals now to guard galleons
drop like they increase the drop rate
that guy was super harder to get so if
you get in there everyone am i for every
Ford run it was either go like 1200
ghosts or sparrows yeah cuz it only
dropped specifically from Bogosian maybe
not drop from ville under it won't drop
from the other one is a Nagi you got but
yeah but I got a good what you call it
or Gaillard it's good I think I'm using
my galleon more because there's a better
role I think I have like rampage and I'm
gonna say snapshot well have a serious
role on my that sounds pretty solid yeah
but it's not as stable and snappier than
summoner
so when I get a god role summoner then I
already know something's gonna beat it
cannot be it just feels better
interesting yeah wait a minute you got
it from Ville under really my bad
three one day that's right interesting
he say you helps to have maximum temper
okay
maybe yeah Oh killing the two little
dudes and the two little floating ghosts
every times yes
maximum temper Prescott did I did not
know that
thanks for educating me shameful unders
those are easy to shoot too so yeah
under is easy to get to tempered it cuz
all I get from London is what you get
which is to Dan Sparrow and ghost oh my
god so many ghosts I had like five of
the same ghost as I was and there's like
Oh get it out most master was full of
those damn things why have you been
spending time and for just sir what what
pulled you into forges a year and a half
later what have you been playing
what could possibly force me to go into
voyages oh I wonder metals well where do
we start Guardian games itself basically
yeah apparently there's this giant
conspiracy theory and the Titans have
been cheating there's animations of
Titans just doing forever dunking you've
got to assume that it's just waited so
much more in the Titan class the hunters
just switched over the ease of use of
the Titans I'm looking at you in one of
y'all and chat yeah so before they
officially dropped all this crazy data
did word did you have any conspiracy
theories what were you thinking about
all this stuff when it first happened
he's got performance enhancing Guardian
here before he has to go listen when I
first heard it I'm not okay honestly I
was shocked because the first day was
hunter
oh man hunt is gonna run away with this
thing this is then alright day to Titan
day 3 Titan and I'm like and then you
know when you start seeing the graphs
and the imagery of the flagpoles and I'm
just like wow yeah and honestly my
theory is this I don't think there's any
foul play
I never felt that way but I do feel
sorry Hunter's I feel that most of you
guys use hunters in PvP hunters that I
know I should say they love hunter and
pvp but it's just
not gonna say it's fixed I'm just gonna
say that it's easier for Titans to do
the melee stuff and then you got to
scull fur and it's it's it's just
conducive it's more synergetic and to
get that stuff done easier so I think
it's a combination of that combined with
people who want heir apparent so they
like your if I want it fast Titan is the
way to go in my opinion so I think it's
more people picking Titan because Titan
is poplin yes but also because they want
this achievement they want this triumph
and if you want to be efficient hey you
know what to do
so that's where I'm at with it I think
it's an efficiency thing as opposed to
in the combination with Titans are
powerful of a beasty and popular so it's
a it's a whole melting pot of things
going in I'm disappointed in the hunters
and warlocks right now I'm very this
point all the warlocks very I feel like
they're gonna hold down second place so
you guys are just gonna have that silver
button sitting out there oh the silver
can I would just like to see what gold
looks like we need a win one like it's
like we've never gone on the first day
you get to see what it looks like that
was just your little preview though the
preview stuck itself with Germanicus but
yet man is your way is just the dominant
class apparently apparently crayons are
just easy modo I mean they had to make
it easy on the crayon eaters cuz we're
not too smart so they had to go ahead
and make all the bounties like much
easier and simpler cuz we're just
walking around in toddler mode so it was
just nice but then made everything a lot
a lot just nicer to us really in general
all the other classes they got screwed
on down ease everything's just insanely
difficult sarcasm is so thick right now
I hope you can tell yeah but shout out
to warlock stuff being bugged I want to
comment on that that devourer
foolishness I'm not pro King super with
killing people with five on the Nova
bomb but a super is not rocking like
seriously broken void subclass bounties
shout out to that awesome
yes hunters bug - yeah it's like all
these things man he said they did a
sturdy
ohdid chad is hilarious I was like I
will say I mean apparently we're just
the easy mode class so I'll take it
I never would honestly guess that it
would have been this cuz the first day
is the switch and then like as Prescott
saying it's like if you look at the the
switch of like the number of hunters
that played and like you move that
number up to the Titans that like the
folds more and more everybody's like oh
these are easier and more and more
people switch from that character to the
other character so that's an additional
thing would shout out to Bungie for
having to come up with a whole series of
paragraphs to explain why there's no
foul play yeah how much do I scroll
there's a lot of text in here just to
show that they're not cheating but I
like how they had to get the numbers
like ah they got data graphs like come
here how bad for the people who would
say it was rigged cuz they are getting
like loud right now it's funny shot the
cat got some funny tweets on this too
it's it's really really funny sounds
like outside of the Bounty's themselves
though all three classes can make all
the laurels they ever need to make yeah
like the laurels themselves going
through matches doing all that type of
stuff if you're like hey I just need to
do bounties mm-hmm some of those take a
little bit longer on the Warlock I'm not
gonna argue hunters can I got a little
bit there's some that kind of suck like
they're very specific ones you gotta get
this from long range kills and stuff
those are shield throws from long range
I'm like how far do I have to be I'm
like going into a loss sector trying to
back up against the wall and be like
redic push see if it'll actually work
yeah and that's kind of the thing to for
and that's all like hunters complain a
lot I would say warlocks probably got
the bigger shaft in general yes the
smoke bomb sucks I'll give you that one
hunters I'm not gonna argue because I
even went through that one when I was
going through all three fine but crown
of tempest is pretty beastly son Bray's
son bracers some bracelet is really
Celestia fire son bracers stayed
refills your Celestia flyer throw it
again cook the ground and just over and
over and so like shadow when I will time
Ankara if you need them double melees
yeah mm-hmm so I mean each I will say
like when I was going through my one of
my I think my exotics video I did the
Titans had like two or three exotics
there weren't that many that really
helped for specific builds per se yeah
but they're like ice or the Titans that
one of the hunters in the world lot so
you guys have like this one can help you
here this one can help you here kept
racing will help you here this one young
Omkar spine is if you need solar grenade
damage or this one helps you over here
there's a lot the whole like goes
specifically towards certain things so
if you had a big array of exotics you
can actually have a little special
special speciality yeah we're not really
but bail roll with it you could
specialize into what you are going for
for each set bounty and yeah as like war
prescott set it to if you really wanted
to heir apparent like content creators
or like people are grinded out you
actually play it all three yeah because
you could get metals across all of them
so i was curious because obviously it's
been established whether Titans are
easier whatever moving beyond the
numbers and stuff what would you do to
change Guardian games in the future I've
heard different ideas we joked about
some before with Ares but just kind of
curious from your experience now how
would you set this thing up to be
Guardian games 2021 I think I like the
idea of it the problem I have to be
honest II is that which we're gonna talk
about in the 12 is that it's too bout
the bounty forcing of the styles it's
too much it's like okay now I got a
switch to solar now I got a switch to
book it's too much switching it
sometimes I just want to stay as one
class I just it's too much switching and
then very specific and I'm just like you
know say so for me that is d turn off
because it's like and I'm a warlock so
as a warlock
I just can't switch my class just like
any other normal
after what my outfit after that my
shaders that rock I have to have my
emblem my match the outfit I have to
have my [ __ ] match the outfit I have to
have my spare oh master
so it's a whole process for me when I
you flew this fashion game throw flew
flashes you know I gotta be clean out
here like I can't just put on a art
class and I got food colors or like you
have to match like this is part of
destiny like you know I just think if
that's why your class lost you guys are
just like I'll see ya up too much of the
venue's and not play yeah play the damn
who gives a crap what you look like row
I gotta look good out here like bah bah
I should put my warlock in Fashion Week
like seriously I got some show you some
I'm gonna show you some staff but uh Oh
exercise no I mean it's too much
switching too much that part deters me
and then you know obviously you have the
I don't mind ok the metals where they
say ok destination forge you know I
don't mind that that part because it
gets me to plant activity to do
something and it's a cool way of evening
with gambit I get excited we give it
comes on now I did normal cam but I have
more stuff to kill oh yeah you're right
I suggest what I should be doing we're
more efficient there's a question again
just it's about the efficiency and yes I
gotta pick the right thing so you're in
your menus too much doing stuff like
gambit prime and night falls when you
should be running Vanguard strikes with
Grenadier regular gambit you're just
picking all the wrong stuff you're right
I'm not being efficient I need to be
more efficient and I could do a better
job I just don't like too much switched
I know
it's too much switching then the Laurel
thing I have an issue that now I don't
know if I'm rolling this so let's say
you kill and you don't pick up the
laurels correct
it's not like an item it's not like an
Engram with you miss it it's at the
tower now like you've ever pick it up
there so that is another this stuff like
I was doing um you know what pisses me
off you know it's a good form
reckoning reckoning on that bridge now
you won't lace yourself at laurels the
problem is reckoning want you to move
and I'm running back to get Dolores yes
yeah I'm messing it up for Bochy I am
not a team player in reckoning but did
the timer is short no I mean that's a
big thing at all this is I don't think
anybody's a team player yeah because
like hey so I'm in game but what am i
doing should I be running to the next
point no I'm being a dumb dumb guy
running around the little arena they're
picking up everything to make sure I've
got all my laurels before I go to the
next area
so don't miss out on any of them so that
makes Mele is more beneficial yes so
everybody figures hat how they can get
up close mm-hmm both Titans and hunters
can punch warlocks have a little less on
the melee front but you guys you know
there's some other ways but I mean
either way they continue to make things
that make you play against the game mode
hey you want to go into gambit you want
to kill these enemies you want to dunk
these moats and you want to kill the
boss you're like no I want to go into
gambit I want to make sure every single
guy dies want to make sure I'm the one
who punches them if there's any lures or
any I'm gonna run around these guys
spawn over here you need to go hold on
there's something else I got to pick up
but there's like there's a lot of guys
over there you need to kill no I want
that one more Lord it's way over there I
gotta go pick it up like elbow people
for that goal game plan mm-hmm
gambit crucible Auto pick up I didn't
forget that so that whole rambling I
guess but we're still yeah gambits Auto
pick up I forgot about that yeah cuz
it'll show yeah it'll show it a little
symbol sometimes but I mean even strikes
is strike stuff be like hey we going to
the bathroom hold on I gotta clean up
all my laurels so clean I've got a grunt
circle run to lap yeah yeah it's cleared
out the entire room hold on hold for
just Rick Rick got a question for me
that I missed it um little kindness
seems like Bungie is making all crucible
decisions especially nerf based on PC
platform and not from the console point
of view they don't understand destiny
feels like different game on pc vs
consoles what do you think um as a pre
mainly people be playing I think that
actually I'm not gonna give my time
money I actually think they do a decent
job as far as the separation the cool
thing is they proven that there's a
separate thing like cuz when you when
you look at the hardener now like learn
especially it says 2.0 is gonna remain
in PvE 1.3 on the Ricochet damage so in
next
I'm not hard on them in in reference as
long as it doesn't affect PvE integrity
and I think at least what hard like
they've done a good job now give me a
specific case where you feel differently
but that's my eyes to that back to
Guardian gave us a dramatic just says
it's a chore like vacuuming yes yes I
got a vacuum aground hold on I got it on
my laurels yeah gotta go meet my run
gotta go vacuum this part I was like a
we set up before I think I heard another
Ageless around tray table almost the
same thing where we said it's late make
it a competition to where you know we go
into a strike whoever gets the most
kills they get you know a medal they can
add and it's like a currency and you get
those and it's either farmable or you
have to get the most kills and strikes
and you're actually having people
compete against each other are you going
to gambit and you dunk the most moats
like make us do objectives or make
whatever we're working on and have a
benefit to the mode we're playing mm-hmm
hey you're inclusive you're in crucible
you got you know top kills second kills
you're on the podium you get that metal
towards your class you get you know top
kills in a strike you know you get a
gold medal for your class or something
like that however it is Prescott said
it's like a pick one class yeah and make
that be the way to go like make one
class account-wide and actually just
commit for like three weeks you're like
hey I'm sporting Titans this week you'd
be sporting the Warlocks and just go I
am going to yeah perfect I agree like it
should be okay and you know this week
you know Ark this week whatever and get
it's the switching that really irritates
me that it drives me crazy and um you
know other than that I actually like
that they made me do forges I think I
haven't done them in so long I was like
I doing it I don't mind them per se but
then it's like excuse me the metals are
not balanced either I'm done with the
gold before the silver happens and then
when I got really efficient on the
silver once I figured out the laurels
then it's just like I gotta finish like
three more and forges its finish five
I'm like dude five forges when I get
done with three I'm like I'm checking
out guys
I'm so done after about three yeah I was
like alright let me throw the balls let
me punch the guys and then half the
people in there aren't doing them fast
and I probably wasn't either I'd go
through forges where I'd throw like two
balls in the middle and everything else
I'm just punching and killing cuz I
don't care like that's okay you
literally just doing other things as
opposed to yeah it's like in for just
hey throw the most balls into the center
okay then you would want to kill things
quickly as you could and be efficient
but then you're trying to be the one who
throws the most orbs into the center
right like every mode is yeah 500 Guzzi
it's too much yeah Dakota's right she's
right
5a you get you check out after three
let's move after three like but yeah
there were some where like if you were
going through depending on how I swear I
win at first and Silver's we're taking
longer than gold I'm like how's that
even work like that's the silver medal
that's not like that's not victory here
this is just second place but yeah just
give us the way that you go through the
activity should be incentivized to try
and be as efficient as possible but like
incentivize you to junk the most you
know motes in game but or kill the most
enemies in game but or do boss -
something just be like hey look you know
you did the most kills you get a gold
medal for this match you did the most
moat dunking you did the most boss
damage you killed the most other enemies
like you could get four golds in a
gambit match by doing that type of stuff
so apparently they've got a they've got
to make tweaks I don't mind it but the
other thing on what we gotta get to the
swab is that you know when they actually
said the numbers as far as population
and what people are using I think it's
just gonna be tough for them to because
let's be honest even though they said
they're not men they're not physically
there is some level of manipulation
based on class population yep I mean
there is so you know at the end of the
day how can it it's gonna be a tough
balancing act to make things fair
because they said there were some things
in place because of the population of
Titans or what-have-you a hunters excuse
me because hunters are the most
apparently right
so there's things in place that Titans
can do and what I can do that can make
them catch up it's just a tough thing
and unfortunately I'm worried that this
may go the route of faction rally
because faction rally had issues where
you know it's just one thing winning all
the time just one of the exotic all the
one of this the catalyst previously was
just like all right everybody go for
this catalyst first this one second this
one third and that was all people really
cared about was the carrot I I am
concerned about what I would like is a
silly unrelated probably well never
happened what I'd look at guarding gates
I think Olympics all right everything I
mean I think everybody does that like
the symbols are close so exactly but
what I want I thought it's perfectly way
to put in Sparrow racing mad Sparrow
race and everybody man let's go with the
little we have our track suits with the
cup brawl it would have been real
Olympic you know bobsled team like it
wouldn't feel it very like this was the
perfect opportunity and I don't know
when we gonna get if ever we are going
to get Barrett I miss Sparrow racing
like big time I was hoping to come back
with Lucy no I actually had a hell of a
lot of fun in spare racing week because
I was actually pretty good at it
I'd probably be the reason I pull out a
controller again because I was actually
good with it there yes mr. Aries Cool
Runnings
cool already but no I was like I
remember like top times that I had on
some of those tracks I'd get into like
top ten or five percent or something
like I remember cuz I was like getting
competitive because I got actually
pretty good at trying to win a lot of
the races and stuff and there'd always
be like me and one other dude like
duking it out but I was like I was
towards the top and I had a lot of fun
I'm not probably gonna be the best but I
was like that was just a fun thing to do
and I'm not saying it's easy to make and
I'm not saying everybody loves it but if
that could just be something that people
like work on to eventually get in an
expansion it's just like even if it's
just this random thing hey boot up
Sparrow Racing League it doesn't even
serve you much benefit it might give you
one random legendary if you win just
like drop that thing in the game
give a man to something to do this is
that was the thing her she just out
there feeding the pigeons in the hangar
Oh
Hawthorne out here with more benefit
everybody with more benefit and poor
Manning and we shall see we shall see
but that's all I got as far as Guardian
game you know decent attempt I mean is
this is listen this is grind grind grind
for another week or whatever we got one
more week it is one more week and then
literally nothing is on the calendar
zero is I was like what okay so we've
got the almighty which still has to get
resolved we have the pyramid ships if
there's like thirty of them now which is
crazy wall bunker one of the one of
those dudes jumped like six pots not
five he got a little gun a little early
in there
and he broke ranks and it's like I'm
going for turbocharged but yeah it's
like this is the end of the map and now
there's gonna be an iron banner week
okay there's gonna be like bonus infamy
probably like what is left that's fine
there's this there's a secret so
basically it's the question of like how
does this season resolve its story and I
figured we'll talk about this and we'll
get into the table because he's gonna go
together so we have the almighty which
started the season here's the cinematic
with Savola Anna Bray ship pointed earth
that is the last we friggin heard about
it was the a leg opening week we're like
cool crazy ship we gotta fire up
Rasputin's week three oh crap
or no what was that week six when we
went it down into IO is that where we
actually saw not know one two three four
fifth week it would have been whatever
it was fifth week we went down and I on
we're like oh there's pyramids uh what
what oh there's an almighty out there
yeah that's fine we'll take care of that
weird he got that covered
so pyramid ships I'm like you've totally
like you start the season with that and
then you're like skirt
hey we got this thing over here to look
at you and I'm just like how out like
the way that is like Almighty feels like
even if we blow it up like I'm gonna
watch be like Oh fire pure crazy
satellite laser beams that we've been
shooting up everywhere Cole you blew it
up okay anyways about the pyramid ships
like I'm not gonna I feel like I'm not
gonna care um I'll give them this I
we're speculating because obviously the
middle part is still gray area for us
it's clouded and redacted this that's
this what's going on right now but we do
know that secret you know it has
implications there's this and it's going
to be an additional thing that is going
to be required and I'm excited for that
I mean I'm saying based on the lore
aspect and obviously we have by fall and
last are you about talking something
related to an expansion with the word
rise to make sure we're talking about
okay just making sure we're talking
about the my kids that's as vague as I
can say it we can we're not spoiling it
yeah it's bad when I do spoilers so I'm
not going to I get these so my thing is
okay that is interesting to me you know
I'm saying and when I I like more so I
want to see where that goes and the fact
that they're introducing that you know I
want to see the repercussions of what
goes on with these do these new things
so I've been this potentially I think we
write it off a little too strong because
that we look at the calendar and looks
bare as hell I'm you know I'm not gonna
lie it does you know we just finished up
all our Aram bunkers is maxed I mean
yours is probably max total I'm finally
up to because I'm being super casual
with the bunkers it's like I'm just
getting to IO noun halfway with that so
yeah I'm super slow I've not evolve over
the Rasputin I literally go I get all my
I don't do any serif stuff when it comes
to the public there I get all my stuff
from crucible all my bits from
activities do the other stuff so I just
like oh wow I have 700 let me go deposit
DS okay cool like I'd have no incentive
and
yeah so what you know what we'll see as
far as that but there's new warmind cell
mods in there man you gotta get him yeah
I gotta get those I got but I'm so happy
with the ones I got there's no rush for
me like yeah my shield did I got my
tyrants time I'm good you know I'm
saying but you know it's just a
slow-moving season it's just a
slow-moving season and we'll talk about
how they handle season soon the handling
yeah thoughts about that but I mean even
the way the way the season started
versus to the big giant late it's like
they tease Thanos in the middle of a
villagers one it's like I mean seriously
we're like hey we got Loki coming in we
go oh and it'd be like when Loki lands
and I like German squared does that
thing that's when we also cut to like a
fan else I gotta get my stuff going on
and it's like in the middle of the first
movie we're like hold on we jumped the
gun here a little bit I'm honestly
really I am worried about a couple
things
which we're gonna bring what the way
this season is gonna end is not gonna
live up to anybody's expectations but
they're rushing the pyramid ships in and
somehow the season 12 if the pyramids
are a fall expansion why they didn't
introduce them
next season back literally in September
season 12 is gonna feel weird I have a
feeling if it goes into what we're like
rise topic that's still a giant
diversion over here before we get back
to the main highway that's like hold on
I got to take a detour go through this
crap over here work my way back in and
then I'm good again it feels like we're
one season ahead yeah of pyramid I do
agree that's that's oh yeah that's
what's weird to me yeah I don't know I
mean I'm excited that their pyramids are
coming but part of me is like you know
that supposed to be full experiencing
kind of stuff yeah with that level of
implications so unless they stretch it
again yeah and they're on the cusp next
season they're on the cusp it was like
those should
ships or book in it now yeah which is
why I'm like I don't know if they can
slow it down if they have if next week
is any an indication and we have like 50
ships on there that number that crazy
dude is at full throttles in the front
everybody is like half them are through
the Kuiper belt and we're like in dude I
don't think there's a way they can't get
here by the end of the season it's gonna
be anxious I don't know how they handle
this this is I agree and it does feel a
little weird we feel one season ahead of
the narrative so I don't know man I you
know it's tightened blow up blow up it's
like you make a video some people like
Oh dread not seems like an okay idea
nope it's not gonna be the dreadknots
definitely not to have a Thrun per byph
and then it's like i have to put us on
yeah yeah so it's like oh yeah it's very
very strange and it's very the other
piece that I guess I worry about is that
they don't do that justice as we've said
before yeah yeah you're right they can't
mess around with that like this is a
human this has been hinted for so long
you can't drop the ball narrative Leone
this this has to be told correctly it
has to be waited and it can't let's be
honest our main fear is that this is
falling in this seasonal model yeah as
opposed if this was falling in the
expansion model of September that we
would have confidence is gonna be juicy
we gotta get strong ask me I would be a
hype to look over the summer first
September like logging in on my birthday
and be like Oh dip here we go like crazy
but no it's early well yes
they've gotta listen this what I say in
their defense they've gotta have a
curveball that we're not thinking about
yeah they've got to have you cannot put
the Rideau story in season of the ten
dollar very little story in the season
12 $10 $10 with this this is not a ten
dollar story right now like our 3d
premium Dorito chips we need to go to
BJ's we need to go we need to get the
whole warehouse of them you don't say
yeah
you know what pcs in Texas is it a
restaurant as well no no like the
warehouse he kind of supermarket where
you gotta be Sam's Club Costco we've got
those classic oh there you go
you need that level of you know volume
heroes like we cannot have this little
expansion and they talking about yay
you know obelisk these Doritos no we're
not doing that we know yeah that's got
to be like Game Change Planet blew up
this thing's here whatever it is it's
got that's yeah so this I want death I
want sadness I want us on the cusp of
destruction it's on they are here we are
scared what are we gonna do we cannot
stretch this out with no week low cinema
and then truck no that's why it can't be
I have to have confidence are they just
gonna get Neptune and just start Park it
up and just like backing up over there
so it's just full of pyramids and
they're just camping on Neptune
maybe Rasputin does something to keep
something happy for them something he
fires at the Almighty and then they
pooped their pants and they get scared
and everybody hits the brakes I don't
know like Dennis incognito has like what
I'll be death how did death I need sad I
need we were looking over Sloan and and
we're I saying the eulogy you know I was
a volunteers like that you know we need
something man we got to feel it the
Doritos were here they're not been not
to be negotiated with her bargained with
they here I need that man there you go
Prescott what a nice theory
you see Prescott Oh Maura stops them
I've become she's up there doing
something we don't know so she's just
like she pulls like shadow you shall not
pass and she does that alike she's in
like Neptune of a license what was the
famous line Oh Maris off does not bend
the wheel well she she caught a product
arcs before she got evaporated
she gotta brought it to him yeah her
anomaly awoken yes like good god it's
that last time we asked for these that
we lost K no we got - we got listen loss
is not Osiris
this is the one is it that's what's
going on the Bungie lawyer he's like out
there like Oh whole Kuiper belt area or
never lay the hell out there late no he
don't would do that story and he kind of
had to get out of it with Segura yeah we
can't we can't go easy but you don't get
too crazy you know prophet the prophet
needs to be here so as we've obviously
said seasons are a thing
some have been okay some of the
questionable story connections man good
bad lots of implications of we don't
know yes when it comes to the swab they
have a couple main topics and the first
one is evolving seasons obviously we've
been living with this model for a while
some first set of seasons they had other
Studios helping them so they had like
raids going on and stuff like that this
is this time they are on their own and
we've had smaller per se content in year
four we are going to build a better
interconnected narrative and more
importantly let players be a part of
that narrative no matter when they enter
the current year that means if you start
playing in March of 2021 which would be
like season what would that be 14 yeah
you could go back and experience the
season 12 and season 13 narrative
content we want our stories to feel more
cohesive flow with meaningful momentum
season over season and lead to an
exciting climax each year so that's the
first one is they're actually trying to
change the seasons to where they're like
the bridges between seasons can be
improved we can do a better job
recognizing the seasons prior narrative
threads in the season we haven't
preserved enough to of the history for a
player who comes in mid-year
to have a concept of what's going on so
all of this is stuff we've talked about
but it's like they're finally
acknowledging it so what are your
thoughts when you finally read this
section just a feckless story continues
you know I'm all about my narrative the
the most positive things I will say
about the season structure that I know
everybody's not majority a fan of I felt
that they are at least trying to tell
better stories even though it's not
always in connect interconnected the
best but the stories themselves just
they're good it's just that it's
stretched out too long right so and the
other problem is that if you're new you
know how many people who come to me and
say yo
I picked up destiny it looks good I want
to get back what do I do
where do I start where I get that all
the time from people who went away from
the game or people who just now start to
gain interest so I like that they're
going to give these people you know
narrative you know and a flow so they
know what's going on you have to do that
so yeah I think this is a good start
things a good start whatever what about
you I mean I just like the idea of the
fact that like somebody could go back
right now and experience the same 14
missions because those should not be
lost like those are that's huge stuff
that should not go anywhere yeah so the
narrative is big because that's like hey
we meet that it's like what's this dude
in the tower oh we went rescued him cool
late yeah before you get to play trials
you gotta go get those missions because
you got to save his butt from time
there's milk just doing in the tower
right there's people who don't even what
is this little robot let's be real like
what was that for like it lets you play
menagerie unless you play seasoned
opulence like oh no what I mean if you
come in two years later I guess you
might have to ask somebody yeah
but if you're within a year now if you
pick the game up in August it's probably
good if you pick the game up in
September or wait expansion time you're
gonna be like you probably won't be able
to go back that'll be kind of things so
like in September October fall expansion
that's the point where the saint-14
mission would probably be like Daria
we're kind of done with those mmm which
I kind of get to a point I guess like
you know if you play seasonally you miss
a season something like that you come
back in some missions would be cool if
they stay but it's like I guess if they
got to move it forward
you won't go play them all forever but
it does seem kind of like a bummer that
even like that like the st. port team
machine at some point would truly just
be like Saints in the tower yeah I don't
know that's kind of where we talked
about but with five last time those
little like story like animated
storyboards if you go up to st. 14 be
like hey he was here in the corridors of
time we gave him his shotgun we met him
in the future we saved him now that you
like go up him talk to him it goes to a
black screen you get a little like thing
of what happened if you didn't play
through it or something just a little
bit of a little bit of context
traumatic just said what I was about to
say like literally when you have content
that good since you ain't making strikes
these days okay next at the BT but um
how about let's reuse these assets that
are in the game and plug them into a
strike that I don't understand these are
classic story beats and we had we talked
about what life like they should not
just be evaporated and wiped under the
rug and that's it I know they're gonna
talk about how to talk about that they
are going to acknowledge that but it
just sucks that Saints missions are just
like if you were not there you know oh
well like that that is like that's a
travesty it shout-out to the team that
put in the resources and you know to
make all that stuff happen you know it
was good acting good you know good
strikes good good story I liked it so
yeah not even heroic missions exactly
it's just it did but I bought baffles me
that those type of stuff baffle me so ya
know I mean and that's where they say
things can't grow forever and stuff like
this but it's like I guess we'll see on
that one maybe 100 Gig is kind of your
your mark but I guess we'll see how the
big changes come in the next season and
in the fall to see how much of a
capacity we're really if they how much
they add versus how much they take away
I'll be very curious what the fall does
to really kind of shed a little bit of
light on yeah we're actually at capacity
or we're really not at capacity we're
just trying to say that like yeah I will
get curious what the fall shows so story
narrative going forward that's cool the
next pieces activities as well so
beginning in season 12 the core parts of
the activity experience will live on
after the season is ended so basically
the state for example you have so with
our new approach the new season of dong
concluded we would have left behind the
st. 14 quests the exotic quest for
Devil's ruin in Bastion
and the Sun Dial activity oh yeah
sundial just sits out there I said that
sunset the obelisk so that experience
isn't just like filling up the game
fractal line would go away so that's the
not really a currency anymore so they
get rid of some of the seasonal like
intensive grinds what that also means
like vex offensive would still be around
Sundaya would still be around yeah this
season the bunkers would probably still
be there I guess
and maybe the towers do you think maybe
they rotate it between a planet or
something like that like yeah just give
you a little little road to be like up
Seraph towers over here forget about
this public ramp kind of do it like how
they do for it would be one location
would have rotating yep staying on earth
mm-hmm destiny will still have moments
woven into the overall Universal
narrative when it come when we remove
old content and allow for new content
and stories to grow in his place as
we've said in the past we cannot
continue to grow the Destiny universe
indefinitely there's lots of reasons for
this tactical resourcing as well as from
an overarching universe design
standpoint from the balance of creating
and maintaining content in our ongoing
narrative is a necessary part of
continuing to build destiny to what we
knew I mean we knew this I mean at the
end of the day it's just like you know
technical resourcing you know it's going
to be they can't just grow indefinitely
I I am surprised though about them even
we're gonna get into the rewards next
but them even talking about certain
activities staying
I am surprised by this not that I'm mad
I am surprised that they actually I
think it leads to what you were saying
which is we were more at fear that we
are at the end you know the gas tank is
almost empty you gotta kind of balance
and it may have more room and they just
be being precautionary yeah you know
saying maybe there's more room than we
think and because if you're keeping
sundial and you got room then you don't
say have you keeping or or like the
assets we're thinking about are not
really the big ones like Frye is like a
you know a terrain map where activities
that I a I spawn really that big of like
a data file or is like a cinematic with
a story that goes with like forsaken a
big data file like where's where's
the data and stuff like that and that
was one where my brother and I dug
through and if you open the Destiny
thing it's like audio and video and then
you start getting into data and stuff
and it gets smaller but like audio and
video crap club-hopping it's just all
massive because you couldn't like
impress so much of it and let's be
honest with luke smith's
original you know these directors cuts
you know he made it feel to me as if you
know the decision when he said hello hey
guys wanted a gambits gotta go right
remember he was like hey guys you know
how to be removing sorry that should
happen inset in the fall expansion cuz
there were in the last year so okay
that's what i doubt was my core so you
feel september well he said it was gonna
there was a point where they said like
either dylan one of the community
managers like gambit gamma prime will
survive for this year they said that at
one point so that rough timeline is fall
expansion they said they weren't gonna
be changed into game but perfected or
whatever the hell we want to call it the
one the highlander of gambit is gonna be
potentially like that fall expansion
prey is supposed to be when they make
their decision right and then also I'm
under the impression correct me if I'm
wrong at that point we should start
getting weapon retirement right probably
when that one starts as well yep they
said yeah in Year fours weapon
retirements gonna start to have a
expiration date on some of those things
for in the game stuff I guess the
question then becomes resource wise how
much does that allocate them right
does that truly make maybe it's the pool
I don't know yes I again I don't know
the back end I'm only guessing you know
if they get rid of these DS DS hole you
know series of the vanilla weapons and
certain activity weapons and let's just
say one of the gambits go you know maybe
that frees up stuff um that a very
curious one resource you know its
storage is basically a storage issue I'm
very curious on that front yes I can't
get some vaults place please yeah I mean
if if destiny to is gonna live on which
of course we got a year for coming
season 12 still got this stuff coming in
mmm-hmm they either want you to retire
it or but Crucible you can keep these
weapons forever so then still people
like fallout who like hey the shotgun
matt has changed well I have like fifty
thousand shotguns because I got to be
able to test them all he still doesn't
have incentive to get rid of stuff per
se
especially for crucible like even me
more of a PvE player at some point I'm
gonna be like yeah go figures old I
found something different like which is
sad but like that will happen at some
point but for PvP the people who really
do like the data the testing and stuff
like that go to patrols test it on Greg
like has to cross like mmm there's still
not a reason to get rid of those they're
not leaving they're just not infusible
infusible but what its gonna be is just
why this is the reason why I was Pro I
mean not pro but this is the reason why
I think power level mattering and
crucible a certain activity still exists
because you have to have that balance if
you're gonna tell people they're gonna
stop using it but they can still use it
another activities like level doesn't
matter then you're not really
incentivizing with one quick plan and
banner are gonna be very different
potentially exactly so that's when
you're gonna see you know when you're
doing those night falls you doing those
grandmasters will get actually little
shards that you're doing and no I
haven't done them I'm not even high
enough to do on 10:23 I'm ten 1023 rows
yeah those good close but still yeah
it's it's those activities where you
separate the men from the boys you could
have to put those joints away and use
the new stuff all the stuff that just
hasn't been retired yet so and I think
quote me if I'm wrong rituals might be
coming up on being in trouble
right probably for endgame for sure yeah
for any game you know we're not gonna be
able to pull a mountain top you're not
gonna be able to pull Clues
Windigo I gonna lie he trials right now
mountaintop
oh is it what his team's is just running
three mountaintop hunters
jump buddy rabbiting hopping all day
skying down at the dysplastic so obscene
I literally cannot wait for that
retirement announcer I go mountain top
bro
and y'all know I was mr. M mr. anti well
exotic specifically but how should it
tear when mountain top gets I'm a miss
recluse stovic loose Dan house my house
that was that was the homie right there
recluse the homie revoke I won't miss
you don't miss your vote yeah I get shot
bad too much for but yeah I mean I think
that the rituals are gonna go yeah
that's why we can get no nurse because
they look at it to themself like hey
this thing's out of here anyway so let
them have their fun final three or four
months coming up of yeah you got four
months on those rituals guys enjoy him
or no pinnacles yeah those are honestly
wonder finical czar just like they start
they start getting everybody prepped
like your next season its are just
breaking the bad news by the way going
into that season 12 you know we got a
big level jump we're going from level
1000 abhi 1050 probably I'm thinking
like if it's one thousand forty fifty
plus ten be ten fifty be like alright so
when you guys get to level 1200 for
season 12 because that's going to be a
big expansion jump so your level 1200
little 9000 no I'm just kidding
level 1200 mm late no I'm thinking
pinnacles are not going in September
Dano made me sad
delirium not about delirium I just
talked about it that homie I thought of
that I'm so used it so much I thought it
was like a regular game it's crap oh my
god I was like now that I finished mine
now that I finished my flawless now that
I've finished my faultless off to go in
there and try some other stuff I'm a
miss break nag break Magdalene break
neck I haven't even used break neck in
ages though love babe right next feels
good right now some black wings black
wings is predicting 1100 now I'm
guessing 1050 1014 X easy it's only 50
40 and then 1500 for the fall exposure
that's a bit large bit high
Grizzly's shouting you out on the floor
list Pete
thank you by the way that was crazy but
yeah they say with seasonal activities
persisting the rewards as well so
they're actually trying to have some of
those remain so you could go into
sundial and still get a sundial drop but
potential they're also gonna have the
sundial weapons available as random
drops and strikes or crucible or a
gambit circuits just gonna be making the
weapon pools of those activities broader
with the activity rewards so I think I'm
good with that
I mean just gives you more random stuff
to drop at so I I miss I actually liked
it idea without playing and sometimes I
see a dead orbit or some random gun I
haven't seen in a while comeback 2.0
version no I'm liking it so I'm all
about that I miss because that's what
deep will use to have those cool random
world drops
well you just something happens and boom
he's just something traps so I think
that's good idea yeah I'm trying to look
and see if there's anything else on that
one but basically it to summarize so go
so we're going to move towards seasons
that can be experienced all year destiny
experience should grow each year after
an expansion after have a meaningful
evolving world and a bunch of reasons to
play and then each year we should take a
step forward into a new expansion yes
that makes sense yeah they leaned way
too heavy into the foam oh this year and
I think everybody can agree with that
because it's like hey they're gonna be
here for 3-4 this two weeks for this
crazy giant pyramid their hexagon puzzle
org I was out of I had to go work for
two months and I'm basically may as well
skip this whole season so these are
smarter decisions and I guess they find
ways to have to make the capacity handle
it the activities stay around longer and
it works for the developers to to make
an activity like that goes away in three
months kind of sucks are the guns like
sucks and the weapons they put their
time into as well mm-hm all that stuff
so yeah we shall take Grizzlies they
were getting pneumonic you pull yeah
same deal man I'm trying to get a good
in there fairies I have I had an almost
God well one except it didn't have spike
gurney and I was pissed
it had full court and clown cartridge
but no spike
yeah I agree so I mean they seem like on
paper in words they seem like positive
steps going forward so all in all I
think if they follow with what they're
saying just making the seasons be living
through the year that's a good thing
absolutely bounty hunters do you want to
say you want to go over this with you
I've been talking a lot this is
interesting
yeah deploy our lead design guy Tyson
green
he says Barney's become a central
mechanic for any repeatable activity
concert and destiny so much that we seen
them move towards being mandatory chores
rather than opportunity to optimize we
have some changes coming to help bring
things back imbalanced and a chocolate
based shifting away from the weekly FOMO
EXPN season rankings are currently
balanced around large contributions for
weekly bounties the intent here was to
provide a large amount of progress for a
small amount of focus play each week but
weeklies fall down here because you lose
out on big chunks of progress if you
miss a week they are strained between
too little progress for single player
characters and too much repetitive work
for triple character players so you say
the specifics are in development but
they want to do is make it better by
replacing weekly balance with a
mechanism that provides players with a
set of non-expiring and account scoped
objectives each week that grant lots of
season ranked progress more than the
weekly stay replace that way that or
return on effort is better more
consistent between players II how are
you feeling about weekly FOMO in
bounties yeah it's muted sir humidity
thank you uh yeah there was a big sign
the beginning you guys just didn't hear
it yeah
that was like how you feeling about
bounties here I'll try it again now it's
like the whole the weeklies the dailies
the repeatable z' that you pick up the
weeklies are supposed to be this big
experience boost but if you do two
dailies it's the same as a weekly so is
it really that big of a loss mm-hmm just
like what you the bounties honestly for
me always seem like hey here's this
thing if you play in a goofy way here's
a little bit of extra
it's like that's usually all those are
like if you want to bounty make it be
like hey I got 50 hand cannon kills and
strikes hey you get it roll on the Dyer
promise mmm like the bounties just for
XP I agree seem in theory it's like hey
if there's XP stuff you want to grind
cool maybe that can be for the people
but also if you want to steer us away
from that say when I go finish a strike
I give more experience than when I go
finish a bounty have me do the actual
activities the strikes the forges the
gambit matches the crucible matches the
raid should be like a full friggin level
yes especially to raids like the Rays
get shafted in everything they never die
every activity every cookie baking
ingredient that we're going to do it
should drop you like 6000 laurels like I
don't really care raids are such an
experience that should be again carrot
on the stick
flawless chest in trials nightmare
nightmare nightfall ordeal grandmasters
all need help and rewards well go make
your raids outside of rewards being a
thing but like give me a crap ton of
experience in there let's just those
types of those little things would be
like hey I want to go grind raid dude if
you run the raid this week you'll get
like two or three levels on your season
pass just by doing it like once like you
want to get some incentive like dad's
FAQs I complete it they really have
dropped the ball with raid rewards in a
sense like you say like it debt that
should that lead how much incentive that
would give people and you get showered
at the end and then like wow that was
worth than you'd run it every week
people would do I would read more like
yeah look at it
the only reason to raid nowadays if you
want a specific weapon alright like I
just say I still you still haven't
gotten you know I don't have anarchy I
don't have a thousand boys I'm terrible
I'm saying I have terrible any net you
don't mean that's only but again even
that on its own is still not enough you
can make the excuse you know not to get
a specific weapon but if you are
showering
people even if it's just passing certain
encounters right passing encounters you
know in different as you can
subsequently get faulty in the rain it
should go up it should it should
steadily increase like how about some
shards dropping something it really the
the disrespect raids get from a reward
standpoint and then let's not even talk
about you know no weapons in there you
know for the most part that you know I'm
not really nothing to go crazy about
well maybe the Sun setting is gonna give
him an option to make those a little
more viable we can hope I don't know but
yeah it's like there's no they talk
about the Adept mod slot on future
trials weapons yeah
talked about that as having potential
there needs to be eight there needs to
be a second slot yeah not a slot that
could take a depth stuff cuz they're
like well if he puts backup mag and the
Adept slot on there he is gonna break
our weapons I'm like then you guys
really need to work on some stuff cuz mm
but it was like for PvE late here's a
raid weapon that has I was thinking
armor so I'll do this in two ways but
here a raid weapon where I can put
backup mag and boss back on there oh god
I have extra bullets and I do a little
more damage to a bus go I broke the game
oh no no I did I worked my butt through
a crazy raid I got one weapon with this
thing oh you have a full load of a full
load out of raid armor you're more
powerful I've done the raid like eight
times I should probably be more powerful
like that's the thing I really want them
to start embracing in the fall hopefully
they do but the same thing with armor
like trials grandmasters raids probably
should all I want armor that has 12
energy or so you can actually be like
hey I can throw double it I can I can
get a little bit more those types of
things like do something to start
setting that stuff apart Grandmaster
armor flawless trials armor raid armor
has
you know that has like 12 energy could
be like damn that's actually really cool
and then the weapons have like an extra
socket so you can have those little
specializations at least will give like
dude I actually want to go do that stuff
cuz it okay we're gonna feel the
difference I'm not like I got two more
steps think about this the Destiny
community is so starved that whenever
there's a broken thing like remember
when knife we're all deal with
double-dropping oh my god do you see how
fast people were in there
dude I'm crazy yeah do you know what's
another thing too even though this is
not a reward thing I've been doing zero
hour because I haven't gotten my um
catalyst left my catalyst and because
I'm doing actually I mean it just cuz
the damage is broken I'm doing again if
there's if you're incentivized to do
something and you're getting those
rewards or it's easier that's what makes
you play the mode it's like this so
afraid like you got to shower people
every night it's okay
reward them for the hard work and they
will play the mode but raids mad like we
gotta talk me it's like this the
greatest strength the thing that they do
that no other game is really doing in
the console space and well it's not fair
at all it's cuz division look man I was
rounding which into that rate and yes it
fell in the bushes with the visit to
right now yeah I wish endure was bugged
people actually used it yep shadow who
said that shut up sanity yeah I'll
sanity like number one wish and it was
like you felt powerful when you had it
and it's like up nope too much and again
it's a dungeon lamp and again the only
thing I will shout out 0 was a good one
xeno was a good one
now hearted of trouble yeah you're right
it is this trash you have divinity
divinity is strong I like the vid 'ti
obviously one cave for the random you
know orange you you gotta hit the lotto
to get that joint but um it's just I
just feel the basics you know they just
gotta get that band ain't got to get
that right they've got a reward raid
specifically remember our idea what we
also talked about the raid pinnacle
rotator as part of a you know a part of
a you know a weekly you know challenge
thing to do they need they need to do it
man it's just you know I'm see up
contest modifier Prescott's on it on the
old content they've got the answers
right there it's like do it yeah I mean
that's one thing my brother has said
forever it's like there's so many if
they lean into the RPG more everything
is always able to kill you there's never
a point if I'm level 1025 I go into a
patrol and I'm just like dude I'm
Superman right now you can't touch this
like you never feel like Superman you
feel like Robin in the whole time yes
run it around you're running around a
little scared like you might get shot by
this one dude over there
and it's just like it's weird because
but now like yeah they need to start
doing stuff hopefully it's assets things
cuz again like take something with
Energon energy and twelve energy and
that might be not be a big enough maybe
thirteen fourteen I don't know what sets
it apart not one if it's one I'll punch
them but if you can just something
that's like hey two more energy that's
just a little more flexibility in these
mods we get it's not saying I'm gonna
break things but right it just gives you
more options and gives you hey I can run
an intellect mod with these two perks
instead of a grenade mod so I would just
yeah that would be a thing so anyway
shifting away from FOMO when it comes to
the bounties we'd kind of got on a
tangent of lay out the rewards in
general but yeah like experience make
the activities reward you and then the
bounties they talk about something else
but yeah we'll get to it so I mean you
got the optional XP not critical path
stuff did you do that already yeah we
have the event and a queue go for it
alright so yeah our seasonal free events
also currently heavily utilizing
bounties in their design
haha so we have seen a feedback around
Guardian games being the most recent
source of frustration with too much
emphasis on completing bounties to
participate they don't plan on making
any changes right now but they looking
into adjustments there and then we got
for future events so then we got qol
improvements we don't like that every
place that she just lost with 10 to 15
minutes of loading up about a shout out
to my boy Kai bot so he has been
screaming this he we got a nickname for
him we call him hash tag bounties in
space because this is what a lot of you
decided yeah I agree
yeah we want to make it easier to grab
bounties when you want to do them to
that end we are looking at mechanisms
like some allowing bounties to be
accessed directly from the destination
map yep said this before yep these are
about a further out thinks he's 13 but
Wow why are they so far away why is it
gonna be like December or January when
we get this stuff when we're like we
won't like now I know apparently that's
a big switch they got a they they they
they through the store on the
destination map yeah go fax both places
but these bounties yeah it's gonna take
us 9 months to get these bounties on
that destination manga ever verse in
space quick vs. mobile yes she she's
adapted to the whole situation so we
don't like you to have bounty you've
nearly completed in the middle of a
previous day's play session expires
right in the middle of today's session
well we while we still see exploration
as a necessary mechanism to keep half
completed bounties from hanging around
forever we're going to relax some of the
expiration times in season 11 to give
more time to close out of yesterday's 19
out of 20 Canary kills speaking of
grenade kills we're in darling the time
to complete bounty objectives to be more
consistent
unexpectedly time-consuming objectives
sneak in from time to time and we
generally want objectives and seasons to
be less restrictive in terms of how you
play so yeah man what do you feel about
these qol in the in the event quality of
life in the event I can't get here soon
enough on the destination
because honestly my brother his kids
play on a regular PlayStation oh wow so
standard ps4 I mean that's just they got
it there mm-hmm
there I think he might be 13 but they're
not I mean they're kids like they don't
have like the highest hardware of the
world and it's a ps4 it's still meant to
run this thing hence why we want d3 on a
PS 5 by the way yeah but he said they
will literally try and like load up take
some like 10 minutes you will literally
like start to load and be like like pull
up his Nintendo switch start playing
something on there and be like oh yeah
like just to enough to a point where
they forget about it and he don't want
to play he still been that multiple
times but they've literally they like
destiny I mean shout it out they've
watched all the lore videos they've
enjoyed their time in it but when the
loading times get to a point where
they're just like I mean a 10 and a 13
year old just like want to say screw it
like I can't I don't want to wait on
loading that's pretty bad so but and the
fact unfortunate it's gotta wait till
season 13 I mean yeah it's nice to know
that it's actually on the horizon but
this also has been an issue for a while
so I don't know I mean we wanted
transparency we can't complain hi I'm
not arguing I just like it can't get
here soon enough so if it makes it
sooner cool but sooner he gets here so
yes positive thing overall not arguing
that mm-hmm
but no sooner the better as for the 19
out of 20 yeah
are they just gonna make them to day
bounties is it like if you plate because
some people like if you pick up bounties
and you're like hey I'm zero to zero on
these eight bounties up I forgot to play
yesterday after I picked up these
bounties and they picked up yeah but is
it like if you have more than half
progress done we're gonna give you you
know until you log out for the day or so
like I don't know like how they're gonna
do that hot I'm gonna hand a net that's
a good question because I feel like it
could be kind of like questionable or
not always consistent to be like you
know if you've made more than half
progress on a bounty it stays around for
another day sure now I will say
somewhere in all of this though as
they're saying some of these bound
still staying around some of these
things are gonna be there mm-hmm they're
not making it from what I'm reading here
they're getting some improvements but
we're definitely not gonna make a
complete departure from our game style
late absolutely there's there's not
gonna be this like hey you're gonna be
experience things here these you're
gonna have like three random bounties
that pop up and they're gonna give you
rewards now you don't have you know
that's most of that stuff still gonna be
there I think and they're just making
some tweaks but overall I don't think
we're gonna see like drastic changes if
we do you know I will be happily
surprised but I don't see the drastic
changes yet because like reading between
the lines is like yeah last part is
really making any seismic shifts you
know saying you know the biggest thing
is the stuff that they're talking about
what season 13 possibly that the space
bounties and they spend all of us that's
it but look at the end of the day we
want transparency at least I'm
understanding thought processes that
always makes me happy when I don't know
what's going on I wanna know it's time
it's I didn't realize it's you know it's
made me it is freaking me and we don't
even know what the damn thing looks like
looks like like kamo and Sony
let's get also your controller I saw a
rendered concept of the PS 5 it looked
gorgeous
like the render looked like it looked
clean I'm like I don't think it's gonna
look like that but I don't know we can
do a podcast just over there store net
yours just on that the first city from
being petty with the book of X I feel
you got a shot see your pettiness I feel
you oh but oh yeah like you know it's
just one thing about Bungie I always
respect is when they are transparent
they given us the role map they're
telling us what they're gonna talk about
I like this new series of behind the
scenes though I will say this you know
last week we got the big one on unarmed
trials you know and cheating and stuff
like that I honestly can't wait for next
week because that's my diver verse
that's my biggest I got it is with all
girl yeah that's my biggest thing
because again remember what we said
incentive rewards and all these cool
ornaments and cool ships and dances and
all this and none of it is earn a
booking in and bright dust did they
remember they shot bright duster on us
big time and they've done all this stuff
to give her and then we got her she got
her little outfit in space she got her
little mobile app and you can hit her up
wherever you at and download stuff and
like come on ladies it's so skewed in
her favor so you know this next press
car there's not enough bright dust ways
to earn it it's a lot of stuff going on
there and if they fixed that like we
talked about where byph imagine you did
your solo you know I'm saying yeah you
just got the coolest bomber and all that
stuff that's in your life you get
showers yeah it's not trusting those
remained like taked I cannot armor I'm
getting like fire Knight armor less like
how beast mode would I be Walker and
like playing a lot of this cool star
you know I'm say even you can you can do
so much with this thing oh I put those
ornaments on everywhere I put I would
have fashion game if I look like so max
I would be freaking walking hive man go
in the tower and make make one of the
random like sweeper BOTS crap his pants
cuz he thought a hive Knight walked in
there so so I am really look for
embodies yes this was important you know
Bonnie it's a games to bounty heavy it
that the problem I have right now is you
fire it up you literally think about
okay which ones I gotta get all right
what's and then you can't even hold all
of them because you got all that I have
63 capacity what weird freaking number
is that and what pisses me off if that
it combines the bounties and the
question the quests so you think it all
and got a little bit of Banzai grab more
oh I forgot I grabbed like eight medals
so that took away from the overall
and now it's so frustrating so now you
you can't even play all the way you want
you can't even scoop a ball up right
okay you got it you got to be selective
like I gonna tell you okay I'm gonna do
crucible in this today so I'm gonna only
get these bounties and I'm saying and
then you got a plate that now I gotta go
back to the tower and then only get
these it's just a cycle of non
efficiency yeah and I gotta shout my boy
Chi out we used to give her a carboxyl
has been saying this since the one he's
like I don't understand why you guys
deal with this game it was like this
he's like this is antiquated I don't
know it's so easy I mean to fix it and
they refused to do it and yeah now that
was his main thing so he's very gonna be
very happy to see this I actually
forwarded them the tois bow that we got
to talk about it all and last word today
because um yeah overall what's your
overall feeling on this particular table
with the bounty stuff and then obviously
the ever verse that's next week I mean
connecting the seasonal narratives
making those continue to go keeping
quests around keeping activities for
longer the rewards being around for oh
that's good
the FOMO feel for this season was what
we've all lived through it wasn't the
best yeah so I mean in theory they're
like hey we wanted some things to be
cool I get that to a point like a World
of Warcraft's has Cataclysm it literally
broke the world in half okay yeah that's
kind of a big deal
things are gonna change but up until
that point this thing that happened
three months ago isn't gone so and those
changes all the seasonal rewards all
that stuff 100% agree honestly pure
positive I don't think I really see
anything there for the bounties shifting
away from you know your weekly film oh
yeah yeah like you know if there's like
is there a boon I don't even know
honestly like some of the stuff is like
okay so you take away weekly bounties
but there's like a mechanism that
provides players with a set of
non-expiring and account scoped
objectives each week the grants lots of
seasonal rank progress more than
weeklies they replace like what is that
is that just like hey I talked to Savola
I'm gonna do strikes this season alright
I'm gonna get my little strike badge on
my
Girl Scouts ash here and I'm late I'm
just I'm trying to figure out my head
what that is is just like what does that
mean yeah they say provide with a
mechanism that provides players with a
set of non-expiring account scope
objectives each week like what is that
please
is that like is it a quest that says is
it like a quest that works like a
triumph that we've got now that's got
like stages to it hey you did 20 quit
you did 20 strikes this week you get
this much hey you got to 40 you got this
once you killed a thousand enemies you
got 2,000 are there like stages that
give you progress the more you play and
you've only got to pick it up just the
one time and that kind of I don't know
soz like some of it and feel like giving
away from like hey let me go pick up my
two-week leaves before dailies as many
repeatable as I can't go run strikes hey
let me get the gunsmith boundaries
because I'm at least gonna be shooting
guns at the same time okay I'm down with
strikes let me go back to the crucible I
still got my weekly gunsmith those are
mostly I can tree pick them up so let me
go to the crucible pick those bounties
up alright I'm done with crucible
apparently I'm still awake and playing
now so we're gonna go to game because
I've lost my mind let me go to the drift
wait the hell far away cuz I gotta go
what road fine you know what pissed me
off you missin it perfectly you lose
your thoughts right then the worst thing
is doing an activity and you forgot the
bounties and you like oh I just did this
you almost say to yourself I did this
for free like I didn't even I don't know
god yes I know the point where I
literally go to all the bounty people
and try to synergize what I can not do
at the same time you know I'm saying
because I want to be actually a let me
run strikes with a linear fusion heavy a
hand cannon here with solar damage and a
solid subclass and I'm like what am i
doing
throw at you throw a gunsmith and them
Seraph bounties all about goggles into
that hey all you got chicks already got
to do this today no in life and then it
come on bro and then it's like oh man I
need you know um you know what you call
it cores and I need this now I gotta run
over to the gold spider because he's got
this and then it just it's too much
because of limitations or not being able
to end like you said your back so and
you just want to play you don't want
that like you I literally have to plan a
before I launch that's you now
ridiculously I have to sit there and be
like okay
Prescott bounties is why he doesn't do
builds mmm
right there everybody's like hey you do
these worse that builds I'm like I just
move so much crap around I don't even
care I don't even think about it
you know what else is annoying to like
shout out to dim and all these other
option but we can't even save builds in
the game right I think you say names
loadouts I feel like some places I can
do loadouts but I don't I mean you could
do that with an out an external oh we're
saying in the game they'll be like hey
solar cool exactly that's another thing
like you you literally locked in and
it's just like you know all that stuff
takes away from play time takes away mmm
being efficient and doing what you want
to do I spend so much time doing minutia
when I should be playing the game yep
that's an issue yeah like if there's a
gun sort of thing every week and you're
like hey every one hundred precision
kills that you get you get a little bit
extra like give me some general things
like if I go talk to the gunsmith be
like okay so you go do one maybe you go
do one thing and excuse me sorry hmm you
get like a buff for the week that
precision kills it doesn't matter what
precision kills gets you a boost mm-hmm
or energy weapons or and just like I
don't know how they're gonna do that's
why I read those and I'm like I'm
reading between the lines of what's on
this page and I still have a lot of
questions and how the they're gonna like
the bounties are gonna be event bounties
we're gonna go away from those well if
it's not bounties its cooking
ingredients if it's not cooking
ingredients its that's why I'm like the
way so many things have been built for
so long they're looking at some pretty
substantial changes to a lot of things
yeah
so again a lot September / fall if
they're working on this type of stuff -
again how much more are they gonna add
to the game are their pyramid ships
coming if they put the development time
into the pyramid ships which I know is
art it's different than functions so
they're different teams working on stuff
but yeah
yeah I mean yeah I can't whichever fresh
carrot made that I can't he's doing too
much right now but um yeah it's it's
going to be interesting yeah going to be
very interesting how all of this is
implemented and my I still gonna stand
on my square curveball next season
I can't imagine we do the full scope of
permits next season we can III will be
shocked I was like I'll be shocked I was
like I mean I know by have said it's
like hey Sabbath in and she's at Richter
she's not gonna expose herself I'm like
you know what that kind of makes make
some sense where but for it to be the
big come let the big darkness eat in an
expansion I honestly like if the fall is
pyramid ships and darkness subclasses or
something like that that means the three
is not happening I go yeah but I scary
but but in theory like that's what we in
our minds picture as the d3 thing so if
that if the darkness or the veil maybe
the veil is not the darkness maybe
there's I don't know what crap they'll
come up with but like the vibe I heard
well yeah all I would all I would say
non spoilery is that from what I heard
is precursor stuff yeah taste I mean and
that's what like the mic kind of thought
was with Sabbath oon and that's maybe
the wrong enemy yeah but like she's like
the lieutenant she's the Loki right like
whatever is coming is the Loki of the
Thanos day you go that's like the Marvel
story we get the lieutenant coming to
see if we're strong yeah what we got and
then still there's something bigger
waiting so
however if knots at it like however that
happens that's what I expect in the fall
some lieutenant smaller thing Kiera zebu
whoever whoever big stuff still out
there for their possible d3 because I
don't think they could go full-on
the full darkness right now no unless
they just want to cannibalize d3 because
I think that's what that still should be
and needs to be here so yeah it has two
black wings on it he's preaching what
I've been saying
Mass Effect the Reapers you know
shoulder strength shoulder power destroy
something get us in fear get us unified
you're not I'm saying and um you know
that you got to do it that way but you
build up the tension to get the
storytelling popping I'm with it man
listen little spooky season right now we
all know it um you'll see how it ends we
see how it clears how much weight how
much more liveable season we got left we
have a lot actually well no we have this
we have in five weeks so we have one
more week of Guardian games that gets us
to May 11th and then May 11th is going
to be if I look at a calendar so we give
the 12th week of the 19th week of the 26
a week of a second so you have four more
weeks after guardian games before the
season ends
why do you think I was saying that
earlier is like yeah we got a pretty
even calendar and you were like laughing
at me and now you're literally getting
to where I was it really hit what you
said that because I'm like May I'm
getting excited I'm always probably
getting close it's June 9th so you have
five solid weeks five weeks until you
get to whatever the next season is five
weeks of lite-brite updates that's all
we got like iron Lords podcasters
optimistic Minnie Bonds has hit him with
the sign lining is like oh damn I
thought we was after like 3/4 mark oh
yeah um
bring on the secrets yeah bring on
something we need something man because
yeah that's why I guess yeah obscenity
the redacted the the maybe stuff out
there we'll see you'll retract it we
know we got the redacted but it's got a
hit
you know he's got a hit but that's a
long stretch bro that's a long acid
that's that's that's the hole that's why
my brother's honestly he's like hey I
jumped into Borderlands and I played
through the story and finished it it's
not like waiting it's like it's like
somebody's out there giving you one page
to a book a day yes and you're just like
a lot more than one page even more than
one chapter I can read a chapter in like
an hour man any more I'm done I'm done
with the chapter I need more you gotta
wait another week to get that next
chapter man be like well what am I gonna
do for the next chapter we can read
through that those pages again you can
go back and look at the old pages you've
already got but the new stuff gotta wait
yeah that's tough so it's like it is the
it that's the weird thing about the
store the expand which I know they're
not going to because the giant droughts
it's the way they space it and it's like
we live in this world and the casual
people
haiya logged on on Friday oh cool we got
an update on the wall it played some
game but playing some crucible hey I
logged in on the weekend again cool
there's something like us who play it
like every day are like my god I need
more but it to be honest I still think
this is just this season because season
2 optimal then again season opera's is
when they had resources yep every week
it was and that's just like you know is
to dig at like you said it perfectly
it's literally this amazing novel being
drip fed one page at a time
and you know it just forces you to do
other things until we get that you know
September big juicy thing that we're
used to having and that's the
frustration because there's stuff there
that we want to get resolution and we
want to get answers but we can't get
answers then with stuff that we need
fixes and we can't get fixes so it's
just loop of ketchup ketchup ketchup and
then we have the epidemic and then we
it's so much going on I feel for them
though I do feel but normally I would be
super complaining mode but I've resigned
myself to the fact that look this is the
situation you know long as your
transplant I always say as long as
you're transparent and you tell me
what's going on
I have no reason to question you you
know saying but when you're not I don't
know what's going on then I got a look
at you and decided hey they telling us
this what's going on that's what we're
gonna talk about hey this is why this is
happening now this is why this is not
happening
we just got a whole Guardians hold the
line
it's a tough stretch right now it's
tough hit that backlog man get that
backlog there's some cool games I've
been knocking it out but um Yoda chad is
out of control right now yeah they all
fighting mostly what see it is he's not
trying to be positive but I could hey
it's dark ages it's dark ages right now
but um well for positive things the
Guardians heart the twenty dollar emblem
that they were doing they've had all the
bound Bungie Benny's going on shout-out
to Ares who had his literally yesterday
on Stadium today is for Team chat by the
way 6 p.m. PC fireteam chat Bungie
bounty on PC so fire team Chet and Fran
Mirabella so FM 3 underscore gotta get
there Lou that's my guy right there but
you got myelin games on the 4th he got
for us bolt on the 5th I would not play
that day I don't want to play again way
chill for us Bolton's ek mushroom na
first of all you I need to stay away
from riot and err easily terrorizing
people how it is good to you mm-hmm
no just I'm going through the ones like
once a guild lock power slave like
there's all kind of funny there on the
8th like they got a lot of cool people
in here so they've already broke 700,000
what's good but they broke 700,000 rd
they passed it I think yesterday it
might have actually been during riots
stream when they posted so I broke
700,000 it's all going to direct relief
which is in this time couldn't be going
to a better place right now so all the
people on the front lines of fighting
all this pandemic stuff yes they also
have kilts for kids so that's kind of
one thing they do every year so they got
the kilts going on you can do some
donations they're trying to get their
77k it's going to I think it's wrong
Ronald McDonald House Charities
so that's their donations page you can
go to there
but again $10 gets you certain things
and then above those so $50 gets you the
basically giant plaid emblem so you get
if you sports your Scottish plaid pride
you're good you got $100 for even more
250 500 thousands so there's some cool
award rewards in here nice good cause of
course with Ronald McDonald House
Charities it's going on to event will be
trying to see how long it goes on
because it's saying V at the end of the
vent no later than Friday May 22nd so if
you are looking to donate towards this
one especially a good thing definitely
get in there pretty quick so I think
it'll be going on for a solid two weeks
but I mean that basically covers
everything they did say we plan to talk
about ever verse feedback and some
changes with making to the store in
future seasons next week so these twelve
actually like got some some meat to them
lately which is good because I swear
some swabs we get we're just like
alright not much here cool this was a
meaty one yeah this is good topics here
so it's been I don't know like ever
we've we've kind of been saying it I've
said it air like we've had a lot of just
there it's too heavy that direction i
what I like I don't think they'll ever
get into the numbers but if they're like
hey I know our price of the armors out
here but these armors are paying for
this or like the whisper ornaments pay
for zero our like I don't we're not
gonna get that information but I was
like no I was like I'm curious how deep
they go I'm curious how like reasoning
or strategic they say anything but I'm
also like what is what is the set of
armor right now from ever verse four
guardian games like what is one set of
armor cost yeah I don't know what the
breakdown is yeah I know it's pricey and
ain't cheap too damn much I'm look I'm
trying to scroll through and look here
real quick test okay uh where is it yeah
but it's like an emote is $8.00 the sets
of armor I swear they're like I just I
don't I mean I know the cosmetic store
expansion is 10 what $8 an expansion is
paid awesome
yeah it's like that's a weird 6000
brightness in 1500 silver so that's
right if you want the the Guardian game
set of armor for all three characters it
is $45 that is more than shadow keep
late they say man I wouldn't I'm not
going to do that I I don't care there
are whales who are just like sure I'll
do whatever but and maybe that's what
they do it for because there are enough
of those but I feel like if every soft
and they would even do stuff like give
me a sale on some older things that's
like hey here's the set of armor for
like three bucks I would buy up like a
crapload of those especially if they're
ornaments and stuff I would buy more but
I do not like the pricing and maybe it's
just me and not quite on the
microtransaction model but generally
it's ever it's too much I'm not gonna
spend 10 bucks for an emote because I
don't use them all the time like so many
things I'm not gonna do and people are
buying them because I see them in in the
tower and I see them running around and
it's like okay cool I'm not hating on
you know but it's just like again
disparity we talked about like I am very
angry but they have a verse situation
like normally I'm the most it's funny
normally in past destiny and destiny one
and all that I would be the most company
friendly okay they got this is just
cosmetic right but once they started
pulling this stuff from rewards now I'm
not forgiving anymore I'm really really
going in and I'm dying to see how they
address it because this is something
that needs to be talked about they if
they have wait the prove the pendulum
way too much on one side well I mean I
one of my buddies plays path of exile
for example hmm the games friggin free
but they're like armor sets which looked
fantastic by the way
they're like stellar glowy like demon
wings and stuff like that
might be like a $30 skin but alike if
you play the game for like 200 be like
yeah I'm gonna support the devs with 30
bucks right like that's those decisions
we have a ten dollar content season
which is a small price for some of the
content we get I'll be honest like the
seasons probably could cost more yeah
but in turn when I try and justify in my
head I'm like an ornament tool set for
how much for one character for one 15 no
I'm not spending $15 on a set of armor
and if I go do pit of heresy I get an
emblem I don't get a pew I don't get an
ornament a piece of armor I don't get
anything that makes me look cool from
what I just did so like right there look
if the prices stay high you got to put
more in-game because if the prices
better pay for that other armor you're
making something I don't know
no I agree it shouldn't be I should be
getting excited or reset because I want
to see whatever first got sometimes I'm
just too excited to see let's see what
cool stuffs you got now like it's
ridiculous it's it's it's ridiculous
like whoa I can't wait I can't wait
that is the table I want to know if they
really gonna be transparent how
transparent are they gonna be about
these books
let's see behind the register what is
good what have you paid alright open it
up we got the account registry here
accounts for seasons we've got credits
and debits over here the whisper mission
credited we're gonna go ahead and debit
that out and make that go ahead and pay
for the 0 hours so we got the ever verse
quarter 1 funds 12 billion dollars whoa
man that's really that's working for us
oh we could probably afford a few more
people here ok let's know I'm skinny I
mean they're not going that deep that's
no way yeah but I just listen for these
absorbed it no prices you know then we
add less we also add finishers they've
added a lot of extra resources you know
a lot of funding man it's been in there
like where where does it pay off and
when are we getting the adjustment
that's what I want to know when are we
getting it we can't have you know good
night for rewards anymore and all the
old stuff we miss nightfall exclusives
goal
like the new strikes just stopped having
them like what you can't even throw like
four more guns in there just consistency
be like some of them have like ghosts
and stuff like that which is like fine
but I mean you can't even that even
anything not an cosmetic exactly that's
next week no late he's gonna be and for
those you guys that are here we got a
good guest coming next week it is CB
grace I'm you guys know him he's rated
me recently I've rated him on twitch so
if you guys have been on Twitch you guys
may have seen him honestly ultra nice
dude met him a guardian con he's a good
streamer I think he might be a
programmer I can't remember but he's a
full day job so next week will be an
evening show be kind of are 6 p.m. 7
p.m. somewhere in that Eastern Time just
whenever work gets done so will be an
evening show but we will have him on to
discuss the ever so nice to have a third
party on these controversial topics so
cuz of course like you know we might
agree or not but gotta have that oh yeah
third party this gets a majority
discussion going on in here absolutely
absolutely about you looking forward to
event should be a fantastic campfire oh
yeah campfire child will be good get him
in here I know he's got a camera so you
guys will get to see his lovely place
and nice yeah so I mean I don't have
anything else you want to talk about
this week I know we're roughly two hours
he hasn't been awesome this morning I
mean the only thing last thing I'll say
is that I know they talked you into it
I bet beaver has returned for me in
religious fashion vicious fashion might
you like crashes have actually been a
lot less I'll be completely honest Minds
went up this week I don't know why all
up it was so annoying all I was trying
to do was deposit metals shadow he said
he'd easy Everest needs layaway and I'm
over here you with the invoices to my
axe we need the receipts there if you
need the receipts but on yeah it'll piss
me off
I would land walk to the to the podium
crash go back land get right at the
podium to deposit again crash beaver I'm
like what
is going on with the Beavers so yeah man
it was it was really frustrated like
maybe two days ago yeah oh yeah we'll
see hopefully they can get that stuff
straight now cuz steam we gotta talk man
you gotta talk I got to get in the room
get the higher ups get peak parson
whoever the head of steam is and figure
out this network situation because let's
be real e on battle.net issues gotta
keep it goddess god I've got to keep it
tall on this I'm a battled dad nails
kind of smooth I don't know if you
remember it no honestly I was talking to
my brother about that and he was just
saying it's like battlenet
is really strict and it's like when they
made the switch like whatever anti-cheat
battlenet had built into the PC when
they developed that thing at first that
hasn't been transitioned to valve yet
that that stuff has not happened so it's
been so I mean yeah the valve stuff
hopefully will come soon and I got a
good person for you guys to raid this
morning she's actually if you guys have
ever had and if you guys want to try and
uh get you know the podcast love out
there well the uh you focus went out
yeah I know hold on can't be focused a
me focus promote correctly sure yeah
autofocus mmm because they're available
focused GG action yes so one of the
people quite Lear elated that I'm gonna
send you guys over there so send her a
little bit of love when we wrap up with
the podcast so don't bail want to give
her a nice little raid I was like to
send love shout out to everybody who was
in my chat last night you guys nearly
broke me last night last night stream
was amazing and honestly today you guys
have been awesome so me I'll make mine
ultra quick you guys will find me
streaming as I'm done with Follis I
might be practicing and recording stuff
I might be playing a little bit more neo
now I want to finish video to get to
Final Fantasy that's my orders I know
final neo first cuz I can't just drop
that mid mission so I want to finish
that Final Fantasies next in these
doldrums of
yes so you guys know where to find me
everywhere kognito what do you have
cookin sir any amazing guests on the
iron Lords podcast coming up actually
actually your state your state's be
represented God babe entertainment from
Texas you will be in the building yeah
we got some yeehaw out here yeah God the
fame he will be coming through the round
we'll be talking about everything that's
going on in gaming on our podcast Sunday
1:00 p.m. Eastern hot topics we would
touch the Last of Us situation as much
as we can is please stay away from the
leaks it is spooky out here and a lot of
stuff we got a reveal of it coming from
at least one part of a reveal of it
coming from Xbox series X we'll talk
about console stuff all that good stuff
so check us out and again thank you guys
supporting one scheming that net we're
doing really doing well like to see the
growth they're all you guys are
supported and also I love podcast I'll
get you all the information we go be
getting it for those of you who do that
like YouTube we will be getting it on a
twitch and the I love podcast mixer as
well so stay tuned for that
this Sunday hopefully 1:00 p.m. Eastern
if you're on those platforms you will
also get a chance to be part of the
realm you don't have to be locked in to
know you do so that's all I got on that
then of course but and I always say on I
love podcast the best destiny podcast
you never heard is the last word with my
manic box is all Friday so I say it
everywhere now II quote you can look at
the tape you got to get receipts yeah
see I got receipts that is easy Eva King
gives it up to you he's like yo love
what you're doing
salute so it's good it's good to see how
chat was amazing yeah it was fantastic
today that's that's pretty much all we
got so thank you for 101 last week was
amazing we I was just dumbfounded the
way last week's podcast went that was
awesome so thank you guys for kicking it
back with us yeah last week I was just
like beside myself that was so so cool I
know we had him fill three hours late I
have got to stop I was like I'll talk to
him forever so no that was nuts
but thank you guys very much so episode
101 May 1st we are in May in this crazy
time it feels like this has been the
longest year ever
[Music]
five weeks man it's more than a month
five weeks
yikes so you guys have a minute bit
amazing guess I'll have to click on that
link here in a second but I'm gonna send
you guys over to magic unicorn so say
hey to her if you guys haven't checked
her out ma GIC que unicorn underscore
she's a destiny player also got that
focus GG going on so send some love
thank you guys very much for this
episode it has been the last word